die ersten filme der berlinale sind
gelaufen die ersten tage sind vorbei und
es ist etwas passiert was nicht sehr
überrascht denn wir sind ja eigentlich
gewöhnt dass wir die deutschen beiträge
so oft so ein bisschen gleichgültig
abtun und die beiden deutschen beiträge
die jetzt bisher gelaufen sind von nora
film scheint system brecher und gerade
eben von fatih akin der goldenen
handschuh sind die beiden filme die mich
zumindest bisher wirklich derartig
durchgenudelt haben wie mir das im
deutschen kino wirklich seiten passiert
die geschichte eines trotzigen einsamen
unglücklichen verlassenen achtjährigen
mädchens das so mit einer solchen
energie wird trotz wut durch diesen film
mail
das ist ein das ist die gesamte ästhetik
dieses films bestimmt
und wir sind ja eigentlich gewöhnt an
solchen sozialdramen also das mädchen
ist und es war sozusagen deswegen system
brechen
das dass wir in solchen filmen wie so
ein bisschen formal so ein bisschen
weich gespült werden das heißt dass
diese fürchterlichen geschichten in so
einem fernsehformat erzählt werden und
das macht ihn scheint überhaupt nicht
sondern sie ist ganz bei diesem mädchen
dieses mädchen schreibt uns mit diesen
mit diesem gefühl von vergeblichkeit
dass die mutter nach der so eben nicht
zurückkommt nichts oder sie nicht
zurücknimmt
ich habe auch einwände gegen den film
ich finde dieses ewige die mutter ist
nicht da und ist toll finde ich
problematisch aber die energie dieser
film hat und die fremde welt für seine
geschichte die eben eigentlich ein
sozialdrama ist dass wir aus dem
fernsehen aus einer durch nach dem
nächsten
denn das hat mich unheimlich für diesen
film eingenommen weil es riskantes und
weil es am ende mich als zuschauer in
einer weise mit reis bewegt zerreißt mir
ein intensives gefühl von tragischer
lebendigkeit so zu sagen gibt das ich
kurze sympathien habe für diesen film
das weiß ich nicht
aber ich sagte sofort bescheid wenn ich
weiß ja du auch